hi I'm Erik Bosse inventors in-game
closed the book on a number of Marvel
heroes and story arcs but for a few
others it took those books and try out
the last few chapters and then just put
them back on the library shelves to
watch chaos and confusion spread I'm
referring of course to and games time
heist which as grounded in real world
quantum physics says the filmmakers
attended to make it still splintered the
reality of the MCU into the biggest mess
of alternative dimensions since Morty
pushed the wrong button I have explained
each of these alternate timelines that
now exist name see you in a different
video but here I'm going to explore the
timeline with the most intriguing
implications The Forgotten timeline of
Avengers endgame the one in which the
nose never existed erased from existence
along with everything famous meme so in
Avengers endgame nebula and Rhodey go
back in time to 2014 to acquire the
power stone for Morag moments before
Peter quill would have taken it in the
events of the first guardians of the
galaxy that present-day nebula gets
cross wired with 2014 nebula who at that
time was still on the dark side working
with Thanos along with Gamora evil 2014
nebula swaps places with present-day
nebula returning to the present with the
other Avengers and then uses the quantum
tunnel to beam up Thanos and the rest
from the year 2014 to the present day
that is the Thanos who dies at the end
of endgame along with the rest of his
forces meanwhile 2014 Gamora fights
alongside the Avengers in that battle
and then goes m.i.a but that means back
in 2014 there remains a new branch
timeline version of events in which
Thanos has disappeared his quest for the
Infinity stones is no longer a part of
this alternate history now again I
already touched on this a little bit but
let us dig deeper into this fascinating
alternate MCU so on earth events play
out mostly the same the Avengers fight
Hydra and then they fight Ultron then
they fight each other
Civil War and then they stop talking for
a while but there's no threat from
Thanos to bring them all back together
Thor and Hulk story would mostly remain
unchanged Ragnarok would still have
destroyed Asgard Loki would still have
taken the tesseract and they'd all still
be on that Asgardian refugee ship headed
to earth and know Thanos to intercept
them and kill half of them but
the guardians of the galaxy's history
would be completely different in this
alternate history Peter quill would wake
up dazed on Morag after rody knocked him
out and he'd head into the Morag temple
to which cap presumably returned the
power stone on his return trip through
time at the end of endgame
so either quill would acquire the orb
slash power stone as he did in the
events of Guardians vol 1 or while he
was still knocked out someone would have
gotten there first
like Korath the Kree extremists working
for Ronan who seemed to be camping out
on Morag when quill first got there to
steal the orb or yondu in his Ravagers
who had a deal to steal the orb for the
broker on zan dark quill had interrupted
that deal to steal the orb for himself
and take all the profit now the broker
was presumably working for the collector
of nowhere who was an obsessive of the
Infinity stones and ended up getting the
power stone until his assistant tried to
grab it and caused massive destruction
now Roman at this time was working for
Thanos but once he got the power stone
he severed ties with Thanos and intended
to use that power stone for his own
selfish goals destroys and our conquer
the galaxy himself
so despite thanasis now absence from
this timeline of events presumably there
still would have been a similar scramble
for possession of that power stone just
with different players for example 2014
Gamora is also absent meaning in Peter
quill and that scene with the broker
owns and are in the first guardians he
would have let that broker unimpeded
know Gamora there to kick him in the
balls
that is until bounty hunters rocket
groot who were there in that moment they
still would have showed up to grab Peter
quill and try to claim him because he
was a wanted man but no Gamora in the
mix now alternatively Ronan or Korath or
another crazed elet in their group could
have filled in for Gamora in this moment
everyone in this brawl would have still
gotten arrested bys and our security and
probably sent to the kiln where the
guardians of the galaxy first came
together but now maybe they might not
Gamora was pretty instrumental to their
formation like if Gamora was replaced by
someone else from Ronan's team tracks
still might have joined since his
motives for joining were so tied to
vengeance against Ronan but throughout
the film so much about the team dynamics
within the guardians of the galaxy
relied on a delicate balance of
personalities and temperaments in which
Gamora was such a key component to that
mix that it's hard to know what the
Guardians could have ever come together
the same way
that sweet Red Rover saves and are from
Ronan but there is one thing that we do
know about this forgotten timeline Big
Bad Thanos may be gone but another Big
Bad was brewing across the galaxy ego
the Living Planet
so recently reddit user LJ gore pointed
this out in a trending post ego from
guardians vol 2 is a celestial who for
thousands of years had been planting his
seed on planets all over the galaxy
planning in this plant on Planet plan to
absorb all life-forms into himself
creating a unity hive mind and
destroying everything as we know it
so without the United guardians of the
galaxy to stop ego from doing this would
this forgotten timeline have ended in
annihilation anyway well maybe to go
through with his plant on Planet Plan
ego needed Peter quill his half
celestial offspring to join him on his
planet that link was crucial for the
unity to initiate throughout Peter
Quill's life yondu kept him hidden from
ego but when quill use the power stone
to saves and are the guardians became
famous and ego was able to track down
quill but in this alternate history
maybe quill never had that Power Stone
moment and he remains hidden from ego
now ego is pretty resourceful he
probably would have been able to find
quill eventually also quills a
remarkable guy he probably would have
made headlines for something else but
even in that scenario it's totally
possible that quill wouldn't be alone
it's possible he would have found a
different family unit to fight for and
still summon the strength to stop ego
that different family unit the Avengers
like let's say that the ego still finds
quill and begins his planned plan a plan
plan egos goo spreads on planets
everywhere like outward from various
points like the one in Missouri earth is
threatened so imagine the Avengers
finding a way to get off world like
through the Quinjet and assuming it
would take ego at least a few years
longer to find quill in this timeline
this could even coincide with Thor and
Hulk post Ragnarok so they're off world
as well and with Loki and Valkyrie join
this coalition also you have to imagine
that Captain Marvel was presumably
saving planet after planet around the
galaxy in this time she would respond to
this calamity - so basically even if in
this alternate history ego replaces
Thanos as the biggest threat to the
universe it would be in a scenario in
which Peter quill was there to stop him
zuly joined by a formidable line-up of
heroes more or less the same exact ones
that Thanos faced in the final act of
endgame now of course the Marvel
Universe is a complex place with
infinite independent actors and infinite
possible outcomes
there are various heroes and villains we
don't even know about floating around
out there who could cause or prevent any
side of International which is what
makes this speculation for the future of
Marvel's so fun because this fracturing
of reality has opened up so many would
if scenarios but here's my question for
you do you think Mora what's necessary
for the formation of the guardians also
question - in a world without Thanos
which Marvel villain would ascend to the
office status comment down below with
your theories probably on Instagram and
Twitter at EI vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for theories and explanations
for everything you love thank you for
joining me and yeah let's be thankful
that we live in this timeline because I
think I would lose it if I kept hearing
people say ego did nothing wrong
[Music]